look at what's happening right now in
just one
agency of the government
story came out you probably didn't even
see it ice the immigration and customs
enforcement
ice
blew 17 million dollars on hotels for
illegal aliens
that's that's the headline it's actually
a lot worse than that
we're in the throes of the worst migrant
surge
in american history
it's going to be last year
we took in 2 million illegals 1 million
legals
this year we're going to take in way
more than that
so
last year among the crazy migrant surge
in march of 2021
ice
entered into an 86.9 million dollar
contract
with the non-profit endeavors for a
six-month period
87 million dollars for six months for
what purpose to house illegal aliens
must be nice must be nice to be put up
at a hotel so the money was for
1239 beds and other hotel services in in
texas and arizona
now this was a a sole source contract so
it wasn't really open to bidding ice
just gave the contract to this
non-profit endeavor why
why did endeavors get this contract and
it wasn't open to
negotiation and bidding in the free
market unclear probably there was some
corruption
then
they s the
this sole source contract spent
approximately 17 million dollars for
hotel space and services at six hotels
that went almost entirely unused so they
spent 17 you you have the government
gives this contract to this one group
then this one group gives a bunch of
contracts to hotels that never have to
use the space 17 million dollars
why
if it were me i don't want to sound
cynical i would assume it's because
there was some corruption along the way
and it exposes something about the
illegal immigration problem that it's so
basic that we almost overlook it we say
why is there a major illegal immigration
problem why won't either party do
anything about this why why what's going
on if only i get elected to office then
we can we can change this problem no the
reason that ill eagle immigration
continues and gets worse and worse and
worse is because a lot of people in both
parties frankly are making a lot of
money off of it the reason illegal
immigration is allowed to continue and
why our immigration laws are getting
totally flouted is because of corruption
it's really basic stuff this is not
sometimes we make politics too
complicated and we get lost in the weeds
of the abstractions of the ideology and
this and that
a lot of politics just comes down to
dollars and cents why is illegal
immigration allowed to continue well
because the libs get more votes because
corporations that are sort of on the
republican side but more on the chamber
of commerce just cut my taxes and let me
get richer side of the gop
they make a lot more money because they
get cheap labor
the government
has a lot of grift in it and a lot of
people are making a lot of money
it's big politics attracts big money
period that's always true oh we've got a
major crisis down at the border hey
federal government give my organization
some money
and and don't let anyone else bid on it
and then oh hey hotel groups i got a lot
of money from the government here you
scratch my back i scratch yours this is
basic stuff
it's unfortunate
but it's basic there's a lot a lot of
corruption here
glad you liked that clip i am now please
ring the bell subscribe get all the
videos don't miss a single second
go to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play get the audio podcast we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]